في حالة اندلاع مرض
في أي مكان في العالم ،
يتم استدعاء خدمة استخبارات الوباء أو eis للتحقيق في
تفشي المرض
، يشير الكثير من الأشخاص إلى eis على أنهم
محققو المرض لأننا نحن الذين يتم
إرسالهم
أثناء تفشي المرض أو حالات الاستجابة للطوارئ
، يعمل فريق النخبة  بسرعة
لمعرفة من هو
مريض وأصل العدوى وكيفية
منعها من الانتشار
[موسيقى]
أنا كاتلين كازابوم أنا
ضابط خدمة استخبارات الأوبئة
في السنة الثانية في المراكز الأمريكية لمكافحة
الأمراض والوقاية منها
كان أول تفشي لي  تفشي تأثير
في الحياة البرية في ناميبيا
، مات أكثر من 200 فرس النهر وكيت جاموس
أكثر من ألف شخص تعرضوا
للجثث ، ساعدنا ناميبيا في جهود المكافحة
من أجل منع العدوى المستقبلية
[موسيقى]
اليوم تم نشر caitlyn هنا في
سانت كروا في الولايات المتحدة  جزر العذراء
في سبتمبر 2017 تعرضت الجزر
لإعصارين كبيرين
في أعقاب إصابة العديد من الأشخاص
بمرض بكتيري
يسمى داء اللولبية النحيفة في المرة الأولى التي
شوهد فيها في الجزر
، احتاجت إدارة الصحة المحلية إلى دعم
احتياطي لذلك استدعوا
في الكشف عن المرض
اللاكتوز أو الكهربائي هو مرض بكتيري
ينتشر عن طريق بول الحيوانات المصابة
إذا كان
هناك فيضانات أو أمطار يمكن أن يتلامس البشر
مع
الماء الذي  لقد
تلوثت أعراض مرض الليبتو بمرض شبيه بالإنفلونزا
ولكن الأشخاص الذين يصابون بعدوى خطيرة جدًا
يمكن أن تكون قاتلة
لدينا 14 شخصًا من مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
موجودون هنا في الأسفل
بالإضافة إلى 25 متطوعًا محليًا على الأقل
[موسيقى]
نحن  سأعود إلى المبنى الذي
كنا فيه بالأمس ،
لذا سيكون الأمر سريعًا جدًا بمجرد أن
يحصل الفريق على تعيينات الخرائط الخاصة بهم
، يبدأ عمل المخبر
[موسيقى]
نبدأ في الانتقال من منزل إلى آخر
بهدف أساسي يتمثل في تثقيف
الأشخاص  المرض ، مرحباً ، مساء الخير ،
مرحباً ، سررت بلقائك ، أنا مايك ، لقد سألناهم عما
إذا كانوا
على استعداد لإجراء مسح ،
نأخذ كمية صغيرة من الدم حتى نتمكن من
الاختبار ومعرفة ما إذا كانوا قد فعلوا ذلك.  يتعرضون لـ
lepto ، يأخذ المختبر عينة سيقومون بها
بالطرد المركزي
أو تدوير العينات ثم
يقومون بتخزينها لتجميدها ليتم
إرسالها في النهاية بالبريد
إلى cdc في أتلانتا للاختبار ،
ما نأمله حقًا هو أن تكون
وزارة الصحة  يمكن استخدام هذه
المعلومات
عند إقرانها ببيانات المسح لتحديد
عوامل الخطر
للتعرضات.لدي تدريب في أمراض الحيوان
والقدرة على تطبيق ذلك لمساعدة
البشر هو
نوع من أفضل ما في العالمين ،
فأنت تفعل شيئًا يمنع الناس بشكل فعال
من الإصابة بأمراض خطيرة حقًا
، والقيام بذلك
والتفاعل مع
الناس وأنت تعلم إحداث هذا الاختلاف ، لقد
كانت تجربة رائعة
لك